also developing tonight new documents
obtained by Judicial Watch reveal how
reporters for The Associated Press
appear to have pushed the FBI to
prosecute Paul Manafort joining me now
for more reaction to this and much much
more
is Judicial Watch President tom Fitton
an American Conservative Union chairman
Matz lap gentlemen thank you for joining
us Tom I got to go to you first you just
put this information out what did the
AAP do according to what you've been
able to see in trying to manipulate an
investigation into Paul Manafort well
just before Muller was appointed they
met with Andrew Weissman it was a senior
Justice Department official and they
brought him information including the
code to manna forts storage locker
which of course was raided a few weeks
later that was helpful and Wiseman asked
them hey go back to Cyprus and asked
them to make sure that they're given us
all the information we need so you have
the AP going in giving the Justice
Department information a target mana
fort mainly to get Trump obviously the
AP reporters according to this FBI memo
of the meeting with Weisman are pushing
late can there be a fara a foreign
agents Registration Act prosecution can
there be a false statement prosecution
can you tell me whether it can be
enforced they're pushing charges on this
American citizen on what planet do is it
ethical for journalists to do this and
then wife's been sending the journalists
assigning them to contact a foreign
government to get dirt on the
president's former campaign manager that
was just a few days before Muller was
appointed and of course Weissman was in
charge of the matter for prosecution
after that you know after listening to
Sidney after seeing what I've seen
happen with the Manta Ford abuses the
president should look at seriously
pardoning all of these folks caught up
in Muller's web and the deep state web
and the obama web well you name it
because the abuses of power the the
prosecutorial abuses are legion and if I
were Attorney General bar in the least
he should be freezing the Flint
prosecution and investigating what went
on there you know Matt
I was sometimes mocked if I talked about
the deep state people in Washington DC
in the Beltway we just kind of laugh at
you but now here we are today all this
evidence mountains of evidence and you
have people like you know Nadler and
shift just scuffing off saying oh this
is political on trump's part how do you
react when you see all this well like
you I've resisted some of this deep
state lingo I think on the swamp people
had it all wrong they thought it was
kind of like you know people pay to play
in Washington this is the problem with
the swamp is is something that's
incredibly serious which is even when
Republicans win the presidency the left
controls the city they control all the
white buildings they control all the
agencies because the places where the
government the federal government
recruits from are very blue areas
Northern Virginia Washington and
Washington DC and you know I think about
Paul Manafort I met today with somebody
who's known that family a long time and
when you think about the people like
Mike Flynn and Paul Manafort who who
dared to associate themselves with
Donald Trump who they considered way
over the line because he was actually
gonna come in here like wreckit-ralph
and really take it to the swamp and take
it to the way things are done in
Washington and you know that that's why
they paid this price they paid this
price if Mike Flynn had just gone on to
retirement and Paul Manafort had never
come back into politics both of them
would be having a wonderful retirement
but they had the audacity to help Donald
Trump and that was unforgivable to the
deep state to the swamp in to these
disgusting actors in the Obama
administration and finally I just like
we have to keep saying it Jason which is
this all happened under Barack Obama
I believe Barack Obama knew exactly what
the wrongdoing or at least knew in a
broad sense the wrongdoing that took
place to try to stop Trump as a
candidate and then as a new president
and and this is disgusting and well
somebody has to pay or it will happen
again to a future Republican president
Matt and Tom I I thank you I wish I
could spend the whole hour just talking
to the two of your wealth of information
and anytime you can weave in
wreckit-ralph to your answer you get an
eight
Plus for me because I love that movie
generally thank you